hey was someone named Samuel Leeds and
today has been a very interesting day
there's been some massive groundbreaking
announcements from the government
covering many different aspects of
finance particularly in property and
honestly I didn't want to put this video
out today because I wanted to put out my
winners Wednesday interview with Lee
Lawrence however that is unfortunately
the interview on winners Wednesday I'm
gonna have to make that winners Thursday
and put that out tomorrow morning what's
more evening because so many people have
been messaging me saying what's
happening well how does this affect us
what does this mean what does that mean
and even worse than that there's been so
many people even the media but so many
people on social media that have been
talking about it and actually saying
things that aren't quite true and
misleading statements misleading
headlines and I just needed to put the
record straight I needed to talk to my
people on my platform about what's
actually being said and how it's
actually going to affect you and
property investors firstly stamp duty
stamp duty it was talked about that they
were going to abolish stamp duty for
about six months and that was going to
mean that you could buy a house up to
five hundred thousand pounds and pay
zero stamp duty that she's crazy and I
said yesterday I think they probably
will do it and I was crossing my fingers
that they wouldn't make us wait a few
months that they do immediately the good
news is that they have abolished stamp
duty not just for six months but for
eight months so if you buy a house now
to live in you're not going to pay any
stamp duty as long as the house is less
than half a million pounds
now the slightly annoying thing is we
are still going to have to pay stamp
duty as investors however it has been
reduced so now it's going to be a
straightforward 3% stamp duty that you
all pay and that's going to be up to you
any amount of to five hundred thousand
pounds so if you're buying three houses
and they're two hundred thousand pound
each you're going to pay six thousand
six thousand six thousand because that's
how it now works and that's going to be
for the next eight months whilst it is
slightly disappointing that stamp duty
was introduced more for property
investors this is good news it has been
reduced somewhat and the fact that
buyers are buying a house to live in
aren't gonna have to make any stamp duty
at all up to five hundred thousand
pounds that's just gonna keep the market
it's gonna keep houses selling which
might be a good thing if you're like me
I've got a lot of properties and
properties that you're looking to sell
but it's probably a bad thing because
people are always afraid about a crash
the market might go down but I'm
thinking unless you have lots of houses
like me and you've just built some
houses from scratch and you're looking
to sell them actually if the market
drops that's not a bad thing it's a good
thing because it means you can buy
cheaper so this is definitely going to
pick up the market definitely within
property whether you're an investor or
whether you are a first-time buyer
you've probably seen me on YouTube
buying houses and telling you how I've
avoided stamp duty maybe by buying it
under 40,000 pounds which you can still
do or getting multiple dwelling relief
or buy instead of buying the property
buying a company that owns a property
and avoiding stamp duty that way these
are all still pausable you can still do
this and if you want to know more about
that I'm gonna leave a video in the
description which you can check out to
learn more about stamp duty and ways
around that however what else did they
announce today they also said that v80
is going to be reduced from 20 percent
to 5 percent if you are in this serviced
accommodation business the hospitality
business that is groundbreaking news if
you are vit registered and you having to
pay 20 percent that on every single
booking then that means now you can
still claim back that from everything
you're buying but you're only gonna have
to pay 5% VAT from 20% back that is
massive and that's going to be from the
15th of July which is almost now right
up until the 12th of January so if
you're in the service accommodation
business get those bookings get that
money they've also made it much much
easier to get planning permission so
like me if you're currently trying to
get planning permission on some
development sites you are might just
about being looked because right now
it's easier than ever to get planning
they've made permitted development on
more things I'm going to be talking
about those in a future video because
it's quite a big subject but what I will
say is if you're a developer this is
good news so stay tuned and subscribe
for more videos about
it's good believe me it's good whatabout
if you've got HMO property and the bills
are really expensive and you're thinking
my goodness I wish that these bills were
a little bit cheaper I've talked in the
past about EPC certificates EP seems
difficult that's what an energy
performance certificate some houses are
just expensive to run
maybe it's because they've not got
double glazed windows they've not that
they heat the way the heating is
structured so that the heating and the
gas electric is really high they are
giving out grants from between five
thousand to for some older houses up to
10,000 pound grants that's not alone
that's a gift to make your house more
energy-efficient that means if you've
got buy-to-let properties the way you're
paying the bills because they hate your
Mo's or if you've got tenants in the
properties you can the government are
helping you make your house more
energy-efficient which is gonna put more
money in your back pocket every single
month this is really good news and if
you've got a company like me and you
employ lots of staff maybe you're
thinking my goodness it's been a bit
tough I've got these staff they're also
giving incentives for businesses to keep
their staff as well so January 2021 for
every member of staff that you've still
got on board they're going to give you
the following month 1,000 pounds per
staff member and this is just a gift
this is just a bonus this is just a
thank you to businesses guys let me tell
you what I think's gonna happen as a
result with this exactly as I said in my
video a few weeks back the government
are going to be trying to get people to
spend spend spend why are the government
trying to get people to spend why are
the government trying to get businesses
to stay afloat and the reason is very
very simple the last few months
businesses haven't been able to charge
customers for stuff because things have
because down so you've not been paid for
stuff when you're not paying for stuff
that means that the businesses aren't
paying tax which means that the
government aren't getting paid they are
trying to get you to spend so badly
they've said pay in August next month
but if you would go out for a dinner
between Monday and Wednesday remember
Tuesday Wednesday they're going to the
government on the government it's going
to be half price now you can't go to a
really expensive meal because it's
capped and they'll give you a maximum of
ten pound discount per meal but still
what's going to happen
that what's gonna happen is people are
gonna start going to out for dinner is
like crazy think I'm just not going out
for meals like crazy and then after
August people are gonna be in the habit
of doing it and they're gonna continue
doing it meaning that the government are
going to continue getting paid their
taxes we don't realize how much tax we
actually pay buy a house 100 grand and
you three grand pay tax
just just foot for what then the seller
pays capital capital gains tax then you
drive there and you're going to pay tax
because when you get petrol you don't
realize that you ain't acting on petrol
taxed on cigarettes taxed on just about
everything then you're getting v80 taxed
as well which most people don't even
realize about so the government are
taxing us less trying Center but they
can only do that while we're buying
things it's never thing with them in
terms of property the people that make
up the rules are the same people that
invest in property the rich do not want
the property market to become difficult
they don't mind it being difficult for
the amateur investors that's no problem
but they don't want to be difficult for
the people who are in the know what I'm
trying to do on this YouTube channel is
that I'm trying to help you not only be
a property investor but be a property
investor who's in the know and what's
gonna happen is property investing is
going to get tougher for the amateur
landlords is a prediction and it's going
to get more lucrative for the people
that in the know the people that control
the system and the people that pull the
strings the media the media is so
powerful do you see what they do right
now the media they are telling us you
look at the headlines that property
prices are crashing it's never been so
bad property prices are falling but then
when you actually read the article and
you look past the smoke and mirrors and
you read the hard facts of what they're
saying actually oh yeah property prices
dropped last month by like what 0.6%
that's less than a percent oh and then
the month before they dropped again zero
point so they might be dropping but so
fractionally it's so little but the
headlines in the newspapers will have
you believe oh my gosh this is house
prices are falling down and everything's
going crazy because they're trying to
scare you and while you're being scared
and what everyone's scared oh just wait
the rich are getting richer so with all
the opportunities that are on the table
right now a permitted development with
the with tax with v8
for serviced accommodation my advice
would be that you get smart you get
smart and you start making deals and you
start making money before it gets harder
and harder so you heard it here first
Maria and Samuel Leeds if you like my
Channel please do smash the like button
make sure that the thumb is blue if it's
white it's no good if it's blue it's
good also subscribe to the channel turn
the notification down on because I'm
going to be putting videos out
spontaneously like this when things
change but will affect you I'll be
telling you exactly what to do how to
investor you need to turn this
notification about on tomorrow I'm going
to be interviewing Lee Lawrence I
actually have already interviewed him
but I'm going to be publishing it
tomorrow he's been in the game 17 years
he was investing he was buying houses
and then when he came to my property
investors crash course I taught him how
to do it smart I talked about HMOs and
things like that
he became financially free really really
fast as a result I'm gonna be picking
his brain tomorrow you're gonna be able
to glean the information if someone
who's been in the game 17 years who's
become financially free and that's
coming tomorrow so subscribe subscribe
subscribe comment your thoughts below as
well I'd love to know what you think
about what's happening I'm very very
curious I'll read every single comment
and I'll try and respond back to every
single comment so comment I'll be
responding if you want to know more
about tax I did a video recently about
serviced accommodation and how it can be
extremely tax efficient you can watch
that video right here also if you want
to see a list of all the people that
I've helped become financially free over
the years you can watch their stories
and hear from them right here there are
real people but please do me a massive
favour comment below and subscribe right
here thanks so much subscribe I'll see
you tomorrow